do you think crackers will ever learn
their lesson
not unless we teach them
can i kiss you like everybody else does
yes okay ready yeah
america the brave
come here nigeria rules
korea
sending you love from above
thank you thank you so much
this is great it's gonna go on facebook
and i'll tag you in it
don't worry then i'm trying to get a job
before you were regular on kill tony
i saw you in the like comedian kennel
just like straight up doing handstands
by yourself in a corner
wow
how comedic
i'll do an impression of you hey you do
it this way do it this way do it this
way okay you're doing it different you
have to do it different
i'm gonna tell you what to do get good
kid so what do you have to say to the
kids out there
uh stay in school don't do drugs uh well
when you do drugs just take half and
then just see how you feel and then wait
like an hour and if you feel okay take
the other half i'm pretty experienced in
like you know
other realms and [ __ ] like that other
realms yeah dude it's pretty [ __ ]
crazy what's your favorite realm to go
to
[ __ ] man probably like the [ __ ]
i don't know
realm of mysterious lights some kind of
[ __ ] like that the realm of mysterious
lights yeah dude it's kind of crazy what
is that like
uh i mean it's in the title man it's a
realm with just mysterious lights man
you don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
are these like colorful are these like
led or what are we talking it's like
lights like made of colors that the
human like the human mind can't even
comprehend it's like colors we don't
even know exist
so are you human
uh
yeah i think i mean i think so i hope so
we all love slavery
slavery
well like sexual slavery
sexual slavery um
we all got holes they they do they do
doesn't matter which one you go in right
what's your favorite hole tonight
it depends on my mood depends on my mood
could be yours this is for uh
vimeo.com
i don't know what that is i'm sorry it's
on the interwebs what in the alabama
[ __ ] is that
where are you from
i'm from seattle
were you born in seattle nah
i was born in new jersey
[ __ ] new jersey
it's all up in this business and we're
just walking
what's going on man atl georgia what we
do for you
what's your favorite part of the
peachtree state
what's my favorite part
of the peachtree state atlanta
what is your favorite part of the
homeless population
the ones that don't give don't bother me
uh you can check out my alma mater it's
called georgia tech
me too
uh are you a rambling wreck rambler from
georgia second helmet
where are you from mexico
[Music]
two nine zero two six three four four
one six
you just made me come
[Music]
you'd rather be a university of georgia
bulldog or a university of texas
longhorn
what about georgia tech yellow jacket
[ __ ] the yellow jacket
oh
my boyfriend's actually 892 miles away
but i love him very much that's very far
away i hope he's not black
uh
he's white and fabulous that's good
because then it'll take him a long time
to get here
you chose b
lincoln was known as a punk ass [ __ ]
and the answer is
a he freed the slaves
he also was known for his hat
abe lincoln all he was good for was
target practice he abraham lincoln i
like to chop at target what's your
favorite type of porn [ __ ] big booty
latinas for real
my favorite porn or big booty white
[ __ ] anything big booty i'll [ __ ]
with what uh who are you gonna send that
to
my host
who are your hosts
i got a lot of them i i mean i got alex
i got carl i got
drew i got luke i got you guys like
small penises
we like do not
we go for a good like medium you know
you know
medium penis
like a grande like a grande yeah
uh did you get it with whipped cream
yeah i know did you
did you [ __ ] in your eye
i teach preschool
uh
so you ate us in preschool no
you're gonna make me lose my job no the
kids just [ __ ] everywhere and i have
[ __ ] on your face yes
she ate ass bro
uh so
why did uh the kids [ __ ] on your face
they just really like her
i am having a [ __ ] breakdown
hashtag [ __ ] face
like already [ __ ] face
i haven't paid for a single drink since
i got here well you're a woman so
exactly
men are [ __ ] difficult as [ __ ] all
y'all are [ __ ] certifiably insane
we say the same thing about you no no no
it is not the same thing
okay literally men are [ __ ] crazy men
need
men need therapy okay
all right well good luck with your pink
guy
party wow happy congratulations
[Music]
this this is what teachers do on the
weekends
so uh what's your favorite thing about
austin
how much i underrated i had it
how much what i i like i had it so
underrated i didn't expect it to be like
this
what's up i'm trying to be a famous too
oh yeah yeah what do you have to offer
uh
i got some coke
can you do a dance
do a dance he could do a dance
do a dance can you do a dance dance yes
everybody dance
so uh what do you have to say
have you met an austin and austin
what what's your favorite type of bird
oh a cockatoo what's your favorite type
of bird boy
ostrich
ostrich yeah
what type of ostrich yeah i mean black
no i'm talking about white ones
white ones uh trashy
no are you guys like part of a team or
something you're on the basketball team
yeah oh yeah who are you guys playing
what it's not the season
oh so
what are you doing who's playing yet
pre-season
this is the most
the most jewish basketball team i've
ever seen give me an important question
are you jewish
i am not jewish
i'm anti-facts machine oh fast so like
what do you thought what are your
thoughts on printers
i [ __ ] hate printers
okay fair enough
i think the colored printers should be
separated we don't have a tick tock it's
a youtube why don't you have a picture
we're going to start one are you on tick
tock i am on tick tock can i ask what's
this for
take talk is it for tick tock yeah oh
sick
hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ben i'm here with my good friend olivia
olivia goes to the university of
tulane university the olympia is a
tulane university and she's a sophomore
she's from houston texas
and
she really is into
butterflies and anything outdoors as
well as um
we love america here we love texas a m
we love
trump
i'm from nashville tennessee we can tell
what's up ladies
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah what am i
singing what are you gonna sing i don't
know
oh yeah sing a song
can you guys sing a song it's the world
really square because
we're not
whoa
you got us we're a sham company and we
don't deserve your respect i know it
you're not right what do you have to say
to that lady over there do you think
that she's gonna make a full recovery
tonight i hope so i hope so
that's intense
that's intense i
[Music]
flukerville
and what do you think about these guys
who are nirvana they're musicians and
they're in a band
i think that they're posers
would you like to hear a freestyle
inspired by you sung by me
if it's a roast no thank you but yeah
and then i have to beat my meat because
this girl is so hot she's not she's a
[ __ ] thought
hey oh thank you
what's your instagram
mackenzie dunning
thank you
you're so welcome
there you have it folks say hi to
governor abbott and uh abort those
babies i do love governor abbott so
hello
get out of that chair and start dancing
around you [ __ ]
governor
hey i think you should respect the
governor he works hard
we salute you the governor i please
everyone
i'm from chicago austin is the best
student in the world
[ __ ] 12.
and what do you think about 911.
what do you mean it was [ __ ] up
yeah
what's up what's up
what's up the most important thing
boobs
and i don't have them
but she does